Islam the religion of peace ha ha ha no
no we're not talking about those
extremists truth is maybe Islam's gotten
a bad rap here in western America it's
not fair to judge religion based on the
acts of a few crazy individuals I'm a
fair guy if we wanted to observe a
proper example of Christianity we'd look
to Christ Buddhism to Buddha Scientology
to the alien volcanic rock overlords I
think so for Islam it's only fair to
look at Muhammad and so I've been
reading this book lately called the the
Quran and it's been enlightening I ain't
read all of it but I reckon I understand
a good deal of it mm-hmm now I know how
careful we have to be with any actual
portrayals of Muhammad which is why I've
taken great pains to avoid doing so I am
NOT Muhammad see
so to start unlike Jesus Muhammad did
get married well no harm no foul he
actually really dug this one day my Isha
and to be honest all reports do account
for her being pretty young when they got
married how old are you wait what well
it was a different time in history
people married younger I wouldn't want
to take anything out of context besides
some people actually say she was as old
as 9 nobody wants to marry an old hag am
i right
oh and it does say in the hadith Muslim
book for 21:27 that he did strike her
causing her great pain
wait did Muhammad beat his wife huh well
in sura 434 he actually does encourage
men to beat their wives well in all
fairness in the abdullah yusuf ali
version he does specify to only beat
them lightly and only for being
disobedient besides sometimes you're
gonna smack your broad you've gotta keep
them in order cuz muhammad actually had
several wives
what else well Mohammed did have slaves
he did slaughter a few hundred Jews and
some of his last words were cursing the
Jewish and Christian people I'm still
not seeing how someone could interpret
this religion is violent
listen if every Christian acted like
Christ I sincerely think the world would
be a better place if every Muslim acted
like Mohammed according to modern law
they have to be jailed listen I know
that speaking of Mohammed and any
fashion is short of glowingly is often
flagged as hate speech on here and
unfortunately sometimes the people in
authority acquiesce to these fear
mongers which is why I've made sure to
stick to the Quran and avoid anything
sacrilegious hi I'm not Mohammed so
please Muslims out there if I'm using
the wrong book or if I've said anything
untrue please leave a comment I want to
learn too everyone else out there I'm
issuing the Quran challenge tell me your
impression of the Nation of Islam then
go out read the Quran and tell me if or
how it's changed and to those of you
wondering about personal safety issues
in regards to putting out this video I
took the risk but I'm hoping there are
enough peace-loving Muslims out there
who are willing to stand up and defend
my right to free speech